a ver si tenemos 2 elevado a la cuarta
potencia lo que hemos visto es que esto
es igual a tomar un 1 y multiplicarlo
por el número 24 veces gay una vez dos
veces tres veces y cuatro veces entonces
cuánto vale esto es 1 por 2 2 por 2 4
por 2 8 y por 2 10 y 6 ahora vamos a ver
algo un poco más interesante vamos a ver
cuánto vale 2 elevado a la potencia
menos 4 te recomiendo que le pongas
pausa el vídeo ahorita y pienses cuánto
crees tú que debería de valer 2 elevado
a la menos 4 ya lo pensaste bueno
entonces a ver aquí es muy natural
pensar que 2 al menos 4 podría ser igual
a menos 16
pero resulta que no en el fondo este
exponente lo que hace es decidir cuántas
veces tenemos que multiplicar a este 2
por este 1 y aquí tenemos 2 a la 4 y eso
es lo que significa es que tenemos que
multiplicar 1 por este 2 4 veces
ok y entiendo perfectamente que no
sepamos bien qué es lo que significa
multiplicar un 1 por 2 menos cuatro
veces sin embargo podemos pensar que
este símbolo de menos pues en realidad
el símbolo de menos es como lo opuesto a
lo que estamos haciendo nada entonces
podríamos pensar que en lugar de
multiplicar al 1 por 2 4 veces lo que
vamos a hacer es dividir al 1 entre 2 4
veces que te parece y bueno en realidad
si es así aunque tenemos que 2 elevado a
la menos 4 es igual a tomar 1
y dividir entre 24 veces ahora dividido
entre 2 es exactamente equivalente a
multiplicar por un medio entonces lo que
vamos a hacer en lugar de dividir entre
24 veces es multiplicar por un medio 4
veces y una vez
dos veces
a veces
cuatro veces y cuánto vale esto pues
vale un medio por un medio es un cuarto
por un medio un octavo por un medio es
igual un dieciseisavo y muy
probablemente ahorita ya ves cuál es la
relación entre estos dos números y en
efecto dos elevado a la potencia menos
cuatro es igual a uno entre dos elevado
a la cuarta potencia y déjame lo pongo
de un color distinto porque esta
relación es muy importante este menos lo
que está aportando es esta parte del 1
entre que hay 2 elevado a la menos 4 es
igual a pues el menos lo que hace es que
tengamos aquí un 1 entre y ya después
podemos poner nuestro 2 elevado a la 4 y
esto básicamente lo que es es un
/ pues el mismo uno que siempre ponemos
por aquí tenemos dos elevado a la 4 así
es que tenemos que multiplicar este 1
por 2 4 veces
ok por 2 por 2 x 2 por 2 y esto es igual
/ 1 x 2 248 16 10 y 6
entonces yo digo que tenemos que hacer
muchos más ejemplos y podemos empezar
por 3 elevado a la menos 3 y bueno aquí
lo primero que hace mi mente siempre que
hay un símbolo de menos en el exponente
en lugar de pensar que tengo que
multiplicar uno por uno entre tres tres
veces lo que hago es directamente pensar
en que este menos lo que significa es
que tengo que poner uno entre y el mismo
número pero ya sin el símbolo de menos
que yo sea 3 a la 3 aunque esté menos lo
que hace es que tenemos el recíproco y
ahora si ya hacemos todos los cálculos
este 3 a la 3 es igual
a 1 por 3 que es 3 x 3 que es 9 por otro
3 que es 27 cierto 3 a la 327 y déjame
otra vez le pongo colores este menos lo
que provoca es que tengamos porque un 1
entre este 1
/
y tres a la 3 es 27 bueno ahora vamos a
hacer otro ejemplo vamos a tratar de
complicarlo un poquito más de menos 2
elevado a la potencia menos 3 pero me
gusta poner los símbolos de menos con
este color y listo tú cuánto crees que
valga esta expresión
bueno pues tenemos que hacer lo mismo de
siempre y tenemos un símbolo de menos en
el exponente entonces esto es igual a 1
entre y ahora sí el mismo número pero
sin un menos en el exponente o sea que
tenemos menos 2 elevado a la tercera
potencia aunque al final de cuentas esto
es 1 entre menos 2 a la tercera potencia
es menos 2 x menos 2 x menos 2 y esto es
igual a menos 2 x menos 2 es un 4 y
luego 4 x menos 2 es menos 8 así es que
esto es igual
no entre -8
y ahora pongamos otro ejemplo no sé qué
se me ocurre una fracción está bien una
fracción que tenemos por aquí cinco
octavos y lo vamos a elevar a la menos
dos y bueno pues eso es igual a
directamente cuando tenemos un menos en
el exponente lo que tenemos que hacer es
poner uno entre y en el denominador toda
esta expresión pero sin el menos en el
exponente porque el menos lo que provoca
es que tengamos uno entre entonces y ya
estamos poniendo el 1 entre ya no le
tenemos que poner el menos entonces nos
queda por aquí cinco octavos
al cuadrado y eso es igual a 1 entre 5
octavos al cuadrado es igual a 5 al
cuadrado que es 25 entre 8 al cuadrado
que es 64 aunque tenemos 1 entre esta
fracción y aquí este 1 lo podemos
escribir como 1 entre 1 entonces esta
división entre dos fracciones es igual a
64 entre 25 y listo esto es igual a 5
octavos elevado a la menos 2 ahora hay
otra forma de pensar en esta expresión
que es exactamente equivalente aunque
tenemos aquí cinco octavos y lo estamos
elevando a la menos dos en lo que
podemos pensar es en tomar el recíproco
de cinco octavos y ya eso elevarlo al
cuadrado
y esto es exactamente igual a tomar el
recíproco de cinco octavos es ocho
quintos y eso elevarlo al cuadrado y si
hacemos las cuentas nos queda
exactamente lo mismo 8 al cuadrado en 64
y 5 al cuadrado es 25 entonces en efecto
cinco octavos elevado al menos 2 es
exactamente igual a tomar el recíproco
de cinco octavos y eso elevarlo al
cuadrado ahora eso no es nada nuevo para
nosotros eso es justo lo que estábamos
haciendo aquí
ok tomamos el recíproco de 2 que es un
medio y esto lo elevamos a la cuarta
potencia ok esto es igual a 1 entre 2
a la cuarta potencia así es que no solo
se puede hacer esto con fracciones
también se puede hacer con números
enteros pero bueno el chiste es que
estas expresiones son exactamente
equivalentes y puedes usar la que más te
convenga en cada momento